[Music]
a TV
hey we're about to get to the show and
uh there's a lot to talk about Trevor
Noah we're going to talk about uh
Dahomey tribe there's a woman King I may
uh hopefully I have that correctly uh
but I just want to you know I will be in
Oklahoma City Saturday October 4th two
shows 6 p.m 8 45 p.m for tickets you can
go to Bricktown comedy.com events and
really quickly I just wanted to bring
awareness to this the they have no idea
that I'll be doing this um the people
who run these clubs across the country
and it's a lot of fun Dave and I will be
doing the big theaters you can go to a
lot of credit.com tour you know 5 000
seats it's a lot of fun but there is
something to be said for an intimate
Comedy Club setting and uh Dave and I
often do these clubs in particular the
people who run these have made up their
mind that they will not kowtow to the
leftist rage mob now they have liberals
just so you know um if you go and look
at their bookings but they also have
people on the right side of the spectrum
and uh it's something that they've
consciously decided to do it's a rarity
and honestly um it's allowed me to sort
of fall back in love with uh you know uh
the Bell that I brought to the ball uh
that's how I started in my teenage years
Dave has obviously been doing it for a
very long time um but it was a
nerve-wracking to go out there and uh
have someone record you at a comedy club
and decide that they want to cancel you
for a joke out of context so it is nice
to have some allies in the industry and
it's a lot of fun to be able to go and
actually have an intimate setting far
fewer tickets so get them now they'll
probably be sold out by the time you're
listening to this if you're on audio I
apologize it's upload a little bit later
but if you're watching live October 8th
Oklahoma City 6 p.m 8 45 p.m and uh you
know what go to the go to these clubs
there um whether me Dave whether we're
performing or not
you want to support some businesses that
you know don't hate you and won't Sucker
Punch you well you know what they're
good people and uh they'll never They'll
Never sing their praises from the
rooftop so I wanted to do it for them
thanks see you in Oklahoma City
very good
hey guys what's up lure22 here
so long sleeves
why does Stephen Crowder wear them so
off
yeah let's put all of this together and
the only possible answer is
Stephen Crowder has twig arms
I was able to find this in an archive
cold post
overwhelming
is
[Music]
finally I have concrete confirmation on
social media by that kind of black dude
on the show
looks like his days of owning the lids
are at an end now that everybody knows
he's a beta male
if you like this subscribe and bookmark
my [ __ ] you for when this gets taken
down and also check out my patreon from
the link in the description below to
help me move out until next time
whistlebar out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but I know
[Music]
[Music]
oh that is delicious to a man you're
right that Ecuadorian honey is is nice
yeah dude it's uh not Ecuador it's local
but I can't say where but why the hell
did you bring it to me he replaced the
local honey that I used to support a
mama with a different one just we're
basically saying my honey sucks with a
better local honey all right okay you're
you're off by a continent all right
we are off the beam already uh glad to
be with you busy busy week busy weekend
uh a lot has happened my question to you
right off the bat is uh who do you think
is going to replace Trevor Noah right
he's retiring okay I know many of you
don't care but some people do that's
going to transition into the woman King
everyone's talking about it but they're
missing a few key points here a lot of
people and uh Oliver did a segment on
this with museums about how you know the
British colonialists right they have
items from like Peru or items from
Africa artifacts uh and that sort of
appropriation we need to give them back
but I also want to know what happened
with the peruvians and the people that
they conquered like did have they
preserved all of their have they
preserved all their artifacts and that
brought me to the woman King where of
course slavery is a blight right slavery
is awful it's a stain throughout human
history but there are more slaves now
than ever in record history and the
woman King just ignores the fact that
the homies some of the biggest slave
Traders slave owners throughout the
history of mankind
I don't know how that ties into a woke
agenda here this is the thing is if you
actually want to look at the scales of
economy the United States was not built
off the backs of slavery we've heard
that a lot
other continents were and still are not
saying that there's a moral equivalence
hey yeah but but yeah but
also Washington Post is the enemy of the
people just to be clear they have a new
poll out that says you're racist Maga
Republicans are racist and uh they
employ some intellectual fallacies with
their buddies in a polling firm um
really silly questions like are you not
not racist that kind of stuff so we'll
talk about that uh just I was watching
this I was reading this poll on
Washington Post and I saw it you know
regurgitating the media are they serious
with this but this is the goal right
they want to silence you they say oh
hold on a second not all Republicans
just Maga Republicans right well the
biggest bills that Joe Biden has been
involved with this administration had
been passed not one Republican voted for
it not one
that includes the wimpified rhinos so
who are they working with
when they say hey the extremists are
just the people who won't work with me
no one will many Democrats won't work
with them on these radical agendas so
that and more uh but first Jeremy how
are you I'm well how are you sir I'm
good yeah I mean yeah it's been been a
busy weekend yeah yeah so you got sick I
did it wasn't the covet no not that I
know how are you sure yeah well you know
I'm just fine so maybe it was he was
like one of those uh one of those gourds
the pumpkins with the bumps on them it
freaks me out it's it's the monkey pox
Edition for the holidays you guys can
comment below what are those pumpkins
that I'm thinking of I don't know squash
are they gourds with all the bumps I
think so but I saw one that looked like
a pumpkin gourds are usually longer
right bad timing yeah I don't know what
I call I know what I do with them but I
don't know who I call them yeah who had
sex with a gourd
questions need to be answered I guess
you'd have to ask that Norwegian techno
music festival
Nary an answer to be found you should
see their salt lamp also you know them
you love him fastest man on his feet
quickest way in the west you can follow
him on the Twitter on Instagram Dave
Landa how are you Ahoy good yourself I'm
good oh you have a Wu-Tang shirt right I
do it's from the I went to the Wu-Tang
Nas concert that's Nas not Lil Nas how
is he allowed to do that I don't know
but I'm sure Naz is pissed yes I've got
to imagine okay great how to make it
sort of it's good oh my sky poop injects
his own blood into Nikes yes ah well
they're limited edition well yes because
Nike told them to stop Yes
like you can't just buy our sneakers
pour a vial of your own blood in them
and call them limited this is illegal
why
yeah only children's blood belong on our
shoes yes
and then Apple said hold my beer all
right
before we get to our entertainment
minute we talk about the woman King uh
Friday September 30th we didn't have a
show obviously Nancy Pelosi uh had this
to say about sending immigrants to
Sanctuary cities titties
we have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here
uh
wow
you know you're talking about like the
race from the left the bigotry of soft
expectations yeah that's just good old
bigotry bigotry yeah yeah that's
straight up no she spoke to zero Farmers
to get that quote by the way that was
slave Traders and how many people said
they're like why are you letting them go
up North
[Laughter]
can you imagine if Donald Trump said
that unbelievable I know oh yeah but no
but seriously can you imagine if Donald
Trump can you imagine if Craig Abbott
said can you imagine if anyone on the
right said that I for Crayola we got in
trouble because we said that uh you know
black Farmers receiving these giant
government subsidies would have spinners
on their John Deere they're like how
dare you she just said that
was latinx sorry because she's an
[ __ ] that they're needed for picking
not a joke no not somehow when you mix
Botox and oxycontin it just produces
that yes no she's a tea totaler haven't
you heard oh right right yes she yes
doesn't touch a drop I love how she like
pauses at the end shaking her head like
right yeah right now why is no one
clapping at my terrible statement why
are your head's doing this what does
this mean
no that's what they said Parkinson's
it's time to wrap up is that what that
means right I'll just where's my martini
my speechwriter's crying yes
they're needed for picking hey Latinos
and this is by the way why you see these
unbelievable games made with the Latino
Community also the fact that they want
children on puberty blockers and a lot
of Latino Catholics not really on board
with that but because this is what they
think of you if you're Latino you watch
Latina Latino Hispanic whatever German
you want to use I'm not going to use
latinx you can use latinx if you want to
I don't want to uh comment below
have you known this is what they always
think and I genuinely don't think that
here's the thing I genuinely don't think
that of Hispanic people that ah they're
only good for picking they're only good
for manually don't I don't think that at
all that's that's not something that
would even enter my thought process sure
disproportionate number of them do but
I've always been under the impression
that's because many of them are first
generation immigrants they come here
then they work up just like the Irish
Americans just like Italian Americans
just like many Jewish Americans you have
different generations of immigrants and
then they end up running their own
stores right bodegas very common in New
York City and they give their children a
leg up because these are the
opportunities they have when they come
to this country I never thought
and this is how you know the left does
not believe in class Mobility they
believe that you are set in stone you
have concreatures you come here as a
picker your kids will be a pick you're
Latino you're Hispanic therefore you
work manual labor out there in the field
it's just not something that any of us
here believe and you know she does
that's all I have to say Yeah well yeah
they're running out of cards to play
right now they're just saying how they
feel right
and it's okay because nobody ever calls
them out on it and it's like no this is
fine we can just say this and people be
like
[Music]
right they say it in the software where
they say Hey you know Republicans don't
care about you black voters what do they
mean we'll offer you EBT we'll offer
we'll create a greater social safety net
because you need that right we want to
we want to pay you for if you're a
single mother right per child you need
that you you get it we get it it's the
unwritten rule right black people you
need us the Democrat Party because this
is how we see you they don't often say
it blatantly yeah right but you see it
play out through policies and now with
Hispanics that she just said it
but they're supposed to stay with the
median cartels and make the cocaine
right right who's going to put the heads
on Turtles
what how do you send a message if
they're up north I need another lift
which I'm not that I have many
complaints with Nancy Pelosi the lift
job not Chief amongst them no good work
no it's a two decent things about her
yes your boobs are huge sometimes when
you start in Pottery like you start with
the clay you're out to make like a
beautiful vase and sometimes it's just
it just ends up being a pot yeah yeah
the rest of the face is a mess yes and
you give the kid a c minus yes I'm
really just hoping that she stops
getting like I'm kind of hoping that AOC
you start to speak at that church maybe
you guys can bring it up she spoke at
that church and she was a little bit
nipply out
um what I don't think I don't think that
AOC is an unattractive woman is it is I
think she's a I think she can be a
pretty woman okay yeah I can't wait for
the day that you know father time just
pulls the rip cord and
because I want because I I right now I
just I just hate her insights
I want to be able to despise all of her
equally yeah she just has the eyes where
you feel like one day you'd wake up and
be like wow where's my penis right
in fact she'd be holding it yes throwing
it out of car window but I want to be
able to despise all of her not just her
inner ugliness right yeah eventually
oh it will come out she'll hit the
mother time father time is undefeated
all right Pat brings us to this week's
entertainment minutes
foreign
so again my question is why do you think
late night is tanking uh we kind of know
this Dave and having worked uh in this
uh before I go to the time to close
Trevor no of course is announcing that
he's uh leaving uh The Daily Show oh I
think we have a clip here we go Trevor
Noah we've been seven years since we
started The Daily Show with Trevor Noah
and and I realized that after the seven
years
um my time is up
I uh
yeah but in in in the most in the most
beautiful way honestly then I want to
say thank you to the audience for an
amazing seven years it's been wild it's
been it's been two years
seven years of bleeding them dry
although he says The Daily Show it's
been seven years since the Daily Show
with the Trevor no because everyone's
like oh The Daily Show where's John
Stewart Oh Oh you mean you you're the
underperforming all right who do you
think is gonna take over well that's my
question to everyone else why do you who
do you think is going to take over and
why do you think late night is taking I
don't know that anyone's going to take
over I think they might just do away
with the Daily Show or have some new
kind of incarnation I think Roy Wood Jr
is great honestly and then uh yeah I
have heard Whispers though Val Kilmer
yes
Frank Stallone hello welcome to the
Daily Show
Stephen Hawking's computer that really
would be funnier yes
um Jordan Peterson the kids from
Make-A-Wish
perhaps just a stomach cancer it's the
adorable blanket Boy Yes
um what
I'm look I'm not the one who's doing
that the point is there are a lot of
possibilities that's true if if the if
the the hurdle to clear is just funnier
we're just looking for funnier yes we're
just looking for funnier the world is
your oyster yes exactly yeah also could
be replaced by an oyster yes an old pair
of shoes yes
they also might just run uh Blue Oyster
Cult best of hits yeah so they might
just do that yeah they're they're the
point is there are a lot of
possibilities just be open-minded Comedy
Central uh now for people who don't know
The Daily Show at its peak averaged
about 2.5 million nightly viewers with
Jon Stewart it's great they lost about
two-thirds of the audience in their
Trevor Noah with some episodes as low as
400 000. now I also understand a lot of
them come through plays with Clips
online so the the whole sort of
ecosystem has changed that being said
people aren't watching the whole show
you've heard me talk about with this
show we always go by the number show for
show numbers right yeah and we have that
never includes the the bits that you
guys can go and subscribe on YouTube
Crowder bits or the Instagram videos
right it's how many people are tuning
into the full hour show or mug Club you
know two-hour show those numbers are
really really bad with Trevor no because
the retention isn't good which means you
can kind of trick someone with a
clickbait title but if not sticking
around yeah it's also hard to get
sponsorships in front of them and Trevor
Noah has been bad for business no I
would argue because he's unfunny and
untalented been bad for a long time too
yes I never understood the hiring no and
P some people like them
oh you're right I do yes you do I take
it back yes
when he's like I would like to thank the
audience and like the people you paid to
come in and you told them when they
laugh and when to clap those guys yeah
thank the signer
the crowd animator should be the highest
paid person on that set I'm gonna use a
card term on my comment then I realize
it's not appropriate it would have been
that saved your life there that's the
warm-up hack is just a car wreck with
small children that's how they warm
people up like yeah there we go let's
set the stage for criminal so this is
why I think that late night is tanking
by the way this is from a New York Post
article uh they said people you know
were still joking about Trump so Jimmy
Kimmel this is one of his most recent
quotes Trump's ranking in the Forbes
wealthiest list would be his inmate
number as well Stephen Colbert again
these are some of these are recent jokes
called Trump a horny cockatoo Jimmy
Fallon maybe Trump should help out with
Ukraine since he's had so many affairs
with foreigners like this is the problem
it became a comedy Witch Hunt with
Donald Trump unfortunately and they used
to say like there's nothing funny about
the Obama Administration all of a sudden
they couldn't make fun of those in power
then Donald Trump and now they give
nothing to address with Joe Biden you
have nothing to address with Kamala
Harris nothing to address with Pelosi
AOC I mean for crying out loud it's just
it's intellectually dishonest I know we
get Flack for making fun of of Donald
Trump sometimes for making fun of some
people on the right but this is a comedy
show well that's what you're supposed to
do and these guys get lazy they thought
oh I can just bash Trump forever and
people were just like yay that's still
not funny right you're still not doing
your job there's Iranian sketch shows
doing stuff
and that's just security camera photo
and this is the first time also they're
talking about canceling SNL for actually
talking about canceling it's too
expensive it's too expensive and here's
what's what happens the ecosystem has
changed and this is why we've talked
about that only five companies that
really control all of media right
YouTube I've been around here since 2000
my brother's one of the first Partners I
believe in 2006 or 2007 I did
non-political videos 2007 and the first
2008 2009 if I'm not mistaken but back
then everyone could post something right
every the whole idea was hey there are
no more Gatekeepers when I was at Fox
News I've talked about this they
actually removed my own guest segments
that I would upload to my channel
because it's a fad so now they go oh
wait a second we're behind the eight
ball and we can't compete on this
playing field so they spend a bunch of
money on YouTube so that they can
dictate what the advertiser friendly
guidelines need to be
and that's the problem that you're
seeing right now with with Trevor Noah
yeah it's just it just doesn't work with
SNL all the best sketch people the
people who are really good at
Impressions the people who are really
good comedians guess what they can't
afford the pay cut to go to SNL it's not
like it used to be no it's very cheap
right very loaded to right well
especially the amount of stuff that you
have to turn around right it's like why
would you need 40 sketch pitches right
well that's and they're not getting the
best of the best no once upon a time
this was the Big Show so you had the
Martin shorts right you had the bill
Murrays you had the norm McDonald's you
had the Dennis Miller's you had the
whatever Adam Sandler's Mike Myers Dana
carvey's now those people will not be
going to SNL and the problem is they
still have these giant bloated corporate
business models they have to sustain
that and it's just not and then you
combine that with the downgrade to
someone who's physically painfully
unfunny like I feel it on my insides
like when I watch Trevor Noah like you
have to watch it from between your
fingers yes
and it's just a recipe for disaster so
uh it's actually now we thank him though
we see him as a worthy adversary
apparently not as much as we had hoped
uh Trevor Noah time to close why didn't
they get an American to host and again
Comedy Central tried and those people
also declined and so once more a job
Americans rejected is now being done by
an immigrant
time to close
endings and Beginnings are ending in
beginning now awesome now I can show my
dick to strangers
cute Mr President Donald Trump does he
remind you a little bits of Egyptian
leaders you were using racism to be
entertained maybe aborigine women do
special things like jump on top of you
and just be like whoa
but it's time for things to close
I know that
that is time for things to close
[Music]
uh breaking Trevor Noah is now a senior
fellow at the Harvard Institute oh come
on they can't all go there well
apparently they can yes they can how
much you want to bet they had a
conversation with Trevor like Trevor
look um
obviously we're gonna fire you
or you know why you're here or you can
resign and he's like it's ending in the
most beautiful way right I don't
understand this is that with four
audience members going what what huh
oh he said there'd be free chicken right
right no chicken oh it's Trevor hey
who's that guy who it's like Pagoda and
now what's his name in uh where's bottle
rocket who is that man what that's
Trevor Noah man come on where's Craig
Kilburn right
uh I I think token Allen by the way
found some pictures of the AOC oh yeah
speaking of people that we can be making
fun of instead the great nippley one
right so this is AOC a Facebook paid ad
oh this is from a while ago I'm gonna
have to zoom this bad boy in yes yes
please do yeah oh geez she reviewed this
and said yes
she's running that as an advertisement
that was extra not even attractive
you're not the best I gotta be honest I
don't think there's anything wrong with
them I'm not saying there's anything
wrong I'm not saying that I wouldn't
sample stop it
uh by the way also we have a clip this
is why a lot of women wear sweaters in
church it's just an idea AOC was raising
money for I believe like one of those
left-leaning churches do you have that
clip is it with her in the taupe dress
uh I think this is Toby First Baptist
Church in Corona could be you could call
it a sand stable we don't need to be
sticky are you colorblind as well no
beige I just don't know nude let's see
it does Church of Corona there it is oh
my Lord I take it back and come to now
and told me oh that's I don't think this
is the nipple video at the church I'm
like how could that be anything other
than the nipple video at the church do
you think a room full of politicians are
even listening to a word of this she's
not that's not at a church
there was a different video it's about
raising money for a church I think but
it's all right that's why keep in mind
I'm watching a small Monitor and I can
see the tea sauce or nipples and I just
want to know like she's wearing a bra
how does that happen how do you miss
that do they have are they are the bras
ribbed it can happen yes I think so
they've got to be it can happen through
yes women you can comment but that seems
pretty obvious seems like you wouldn't
miss it and then she's of course running
it as an advertisement on Facebook she's
saying exclusively use the nipple
pictures hey look I've had mine poke
through a Christmas sweater well yes
that's because you're only wearing a
Christmas sweater that's true and I
don't know how you do that and I've also
cut a hole Dave that wasn't your nipple
and those are pants and that was a
public stall by the way it's a live show
Monday through Thursday at 10 A.M
Eastern if you want to know how to tune
in just tune it here on YouTube nothing
would be happier than if you all went
over to rumble or mug club uh today
we'll be playing they don't make them
like they used to I can't even tell you
which film it is because we can't talk
about on YouTube so you can go to rumble
you can download the audio podcast or
later with crowder.com mug Club 99
annually get this wonderful hand etched
uh hand-etched mug but you also get
access to a whole catalog of shows
military veterans
um military veteran students enter in
that word you get 30 off I believe it's
30 right yeah 69 okay yeah man this
brings yeah man oh yeah so uh I think
have we gotten that all out of our
system I think so yeah uh sure the AOC
them okay I mean yeah I guess I can't
believe that oh boy well it's back again
that's not a flattering picture again I
just I don't I don't think it's fair to
say because I don't like her that she's
not you know she's not pretty in in many
ways I think I don't think she's an
unattractive woman
that's I think that's fine yeah just
saying that's not enough I'm waiting for
that biological clock to stop working
and then then I can be disgusted with
everything not just Brazilian like is it
just literally going to be one day to
the next is that yeah so what do you
talk about Brazilians no you meant to
say like polish or Italian women yeah
it's like 36 yes yeah Brazilian women
the same way
what that's just admonish him he is
wrong about that Brazilian women are
known as the most he just picked the
most beautiful woman on the planet yeah
that's not true not when they get old
yeah what do you want to pick next uh
Argentina because they only have all the
Miss Universe titles under their name
when they're young yet gross everything
you know how I know you're gay oh okay
like that
sorry Brazilian women are gorgeous yes I
do well until one day they're the the
Gypsy from thinner see there you go
that's my point
and you guys admonished me see see
that's what I'm saying
I'm just saying okay
I know exactly
all right okay don't let me laugh
because I have to introduce to slavery
in woman King and I don't want people to
see me laughing when I'm talking about
it's like because slavery's not funny no
it's the movie you're laughing the Gypsy
and thinner is yes oh okay so uh you all
know about the woman King none of you
like it all right
we've established that not a clue but
here's the thing not just because it's
woke and not because it's this you know
sort of feminist tale and okay we'll do
a review of Hocus Pocus too tomorrow so
hey hey there's a drag show in it what
yes they tried to check every woke box
and the first one was a steaming pile of
dog crap so the sequel is even worse I
mean that's a feat
I have a friend in it I'm sorry
I've been in a ton of crap as well so
don't you ever see Greek on ABC Family
oh yeah you were in that
no
afternoon so it's the woman King now
this film of course tells the story of
the uh the uh go a Goji I believe the
agoji
uh it's this all-female fighting unit in
uh the African Kingdom and by the way it
sort of spreads across different
countries just to be clear so we'll be
talking about the tribe so unless you
try and you know lawyer US unless I
understand that it's not just based on
geographical borders but the tribe
specifically are the people the the
homie uh so here's just sort of for
people who don't know what the film is
all about
when it rains our ancestors weep for the
pain we are felt in a dark Halls of
ships bounce condensation clouds
our ancestors push us too much into
battle against those who enslave us
when it thunders
our ancestors are mine we rip the
shackles of Doubt from our minds and
fight with courage
we fight not just for today
but for the future where you can enslave
a record number of people there too
[Music]
now I know it's a film there's some
creative license that's taken but just
so you know statistically most of those
people there would have been slaves yes
just to be clear just like I know you
thought you know Beauty and the Beast
was a true to form historically no no
Mary J Blige who folds into a bookcase
where the hell she is an armor whatever
she is yeah armor whatever they call it
like a pout room powder yes exactly she
would have been uh she would have been a
slave as well in 1740s France just to be
clear hashtag Oscar so white so this has
received rave reviews of course from
Rotten Tomatoes right 94 from critics 99
from audience which I'm willing to bet
that they've changed the algorithm there
with uh audience reviews The New York
Times praise the film when the reviews
saying the women are their own greatest
weapons uh and among everything else IT
addresses the woman King is about strong
Dynamic black women their souls minds
and bodies okay first off hit the like
button if you can see where this is
going
if you know the film is whitewashed yeah
uh if I mean and by the way to say that
this is offensive would be to say that
uh uh Mr was it Mr yuniyoshi and
Breakfast at Tiffany's was it maybe a
little off color yes
so what you're saying is this was
written by a guy's last name ended in
Berg possibly yes not Peter like black
panther
didn't do black panther no no peterberg
has done some decent stuff oh he is no
I'm just saying that it was like
a Jewish guy yes I'm just intentionally
uncomfortable no I am too I don't know
where to go with you watch this movie as
well the woman King first off women are
their own greatest weapon
okay now
let's get maybe if you're talking about
like women who own slaves in the homie
tribes by the way maybe if that's what
you're discussing I mean like they're
their own greatest weapon because they
have like a mountain of slaves behind
them they have so many slaves it's like
World War Z On The Wall yeah so this is
the issue slavery is bad we all agree
okay it's bad that the United States
engages no one disagrees with that just
to be clear
our primary problem is that there are
more slaves today than ever in recorded
history that's a fact and our problem is
that we talk often in school about how
the United States was built off the
backs of slaves but if you look at the
numbers it's really not true you can go
and search or go on Mud Club for the
band segments I don't think it's still
on YouTube where we actually compare the
development of the South with slavery
versus the North and slavery actually
impeded progress economic progress in
the United States because it turns out
that a lot of slaves who are forced not
the most ingenious workers right these
people don't have an incentive to work
particularly hard you look at the cotton
gin I believe that came from the north
there are a bunch of uh innovations that
came from the north where there were
people who were free who were working
right because of a voluntary exchange of
goods and services yeah but if you look
at a lot of these African nations and
certainly if you look at the Middle East
Asia where there is still slavery by the
way their economy required the
foundation the Bedrock of the economy
was slavery as a matter of fact if we
didn't purchase slaves from them they
probably would have had no International
Trade which to speak are you saying that
it wasn't the colonial oppression not
exactly okay gotcha well I don't know if
the colonialism I mean I don't think it
would have worked without slaves and
black people though in America I mean
that's the reality of that too early on
yeah argue that I would argue that an
impeded American development because
again if you look at the North when they
freed you know obviously they didn't
have slaves far earlier than the South
yeah they Advanced far more rapidly
economically and if you look at these
nations that are still slave Nations
yeah they don't tend to develop they
don't tend to innovate because people
are forced to go in and punch a clock
and they don't necessarily do the best
work that they can
it's but but I understand in other words
I can see both sides of that coin no one
is disagreeing that slavery was wrong
and that slavery plays a role in
American history why do we whitewash
though slavery that still go if you want
to help the world let's not talk about
puberty blockers for six-year-olds and
you know calling CPS and the parents who
don't administer them let's talk about
slavery going on throughout but to do
that you have to acknowledge the past
and you have to acknowledge a present
and you have to acknowledge that we
committed an evil engaging in slavery
but we also end it we eradicated one of
the greatest evils in the Western World
so let's go through the claims basically
and these are implicit in the film so
one of the premises a claim first is uh
that the home the Dahomey tribe I hope
I'm saying that right because I'm like
is that where homie came from the homies
like rolling with the homies
they were a decent people with a
beautiful way of life and they were
these Warrior Kings sorry Queens well
female King woman King whatever it's
stupid so here's the truth uh they were
an incredibly barbaric tribe yeah in a
way that you can't fathom here in the
western world and the actual homie
kingdom was uh unbelief they were an
unbelievably big player in the slave
trade so here's according to National
Geographic not a right-wing propaganda
rag no it's estimated that from the
1720s until 1852 when the British
imposed a naval blockade the homies
rulers sold hundreds of thousands of
people from neighboring tribes and
Nations to the British French Portuguese
and others hundreds of thousands now if
someone sells you something for example
that is faulty let's say you buy let's
say you buy a used car and that's
defective do you blame the person who
purchased it
and I'm not comparing people to a core
I'm just using this as an analogy just
to be clear or do you blame the person
who committed the wrong in lying in the
sale why don't we blame the people at
least equally if not I would say weigh
it more on their side who captured
people enslaved them and sold them as
opposed to people who purchased them
I just think that we need to have an
equal distribution of blame so the homie
tribe by the way they also instituted
not just slavery large-scale human
sacrifices
they save the decapitated heads genitals
of their enemies and took them back to
the villages with them what do you do
with those I understand the heads the
skulls I mean trophy case yeah the sun
dry them jerky I mean some are bigger
than others right so yeah you play the
big ones on the top
I don't understand it's like okay yes
after I'm dead you're gonna cut that off
and take it back but you've never walked
into my house seen a rhino head next to
my slave people there was someone's job
was to sift through the penises yeah
yeah like which ones no no that's a sh
that's a show penis that's simply that's
a penis that goes in the middle average
penis I'm a penis dermist I'll stuff it
and make it for your wall this is a
champion show penis let me look let me
look that's an
elephant's gun so in the movie Viola
Davis's character uh begs King kingzzo I
do like Viola Davis to stop the slave
trade and focus on palm oil which is
kind of just a funny sort of ultimatum
it's like um hundreds of thousands of
slaves right palm oil
hundreds of thousands of slaves palm oil
what is palm oil that's oil from a from
Palm
a naval blockage here's something else
to a naval blockade by the British in
the 1850s they that's what forced a
homie to move off the slave trade and
focus on Pomo again a big part of
slavery being ended outside the United
States where there was and there is an
economic argument too A lot of people
say if you look at Abraham Lincoln he
didn't necessarily he wasn't he wasn't
Progressive by today's standards but
part of it was economically motivated
but there was a moral component to we
cannot have our Constitution and all men
created equal and have slavery in a lot
of other areas of the world the only
reason they stopped slavery was for
economic reasons it was the market that
forced them to move to something else
like palm oil yeah and by the way so
they they say they talk a lot about
Freedom like Freedom you know we get to
be our own people we get to no no no
they lived by the code slave or be
enslaved right right you either enslave
somebody else or you're going to be
enslaved by them right that was how they
lived their life this was no beautiful
let live kind of culture out there well
I think this is one of those things in
in Jordan Peterson talks about this
quite a bit but we've discussed it quite
a bit you have no clue as to what human
history is like right now this is the
most peaceful time for example people
are furious with Ukraine uh sorry we're
furious with Russia with what they've
done in Ukraine yeah pardon me
why well because they're being violent
they're being violent with a nation that
most people say you know they haven't
been violent with them now of course
there's a land dispute we won't get into
the micro politics of it that being said
at no point throughout human history
would someone have said hey hold on a
second you're reprehensible why because
you're trying to take over a nation for
their resources people would have said
oh yeah yeah let the best country win
let the and by best we do mean that
might made right throughout all of human
history yeah this is really a very very
small window
in the realm of human history where it's
actually considered to be an anomaly
where it's it's not the norm it has
always been the norm it has been the
rule throughout all of human history
pretty much no exceptions to be clear
here's another claim that they make that
the homie in this this film
I haven't seen it just to be clear
usually I can make it I couldn't stomach
no I watched about 10 minutes and I saw
the trailer and I was like nope right
and I didn't know it existed yeah I I I
found out because I I read articles but
the truth is I don't see teaser trailers
a lot anymore
I don't think of theatrical releases as
big releases like I used to right I
thesaurus woman King and it came up
Queen yes
we have a word for it you might actually
be able to pull up the video that I did
a long time ago it was maybe like
cultural appropriation what's that uh
Christmas play that the the is it saying
TSU it's like it's you know the Asian
play they always do it around Christmas
the Chinese Play Always and there's a
guy with the pom pom on his head this
hilarious Chinese man Christmas Story
yeah it's hilarious Chinese
I can't remember what it was called but
they do it every year at Christmas you
guys can comment below you probably know
what I'm talking about and this is an
old video I did I want to say in 2013
2014 where I asked him I said well why
can't it be a woman King this guy was
out there promoting the play and he goes
uh sorry why can't it be a female
Emperor he goes oh you mean uh Empress I
said well that's offensive he's like no
no no no no I'm I'm dressed as Emperor
I'm a man
is Brandon even compute yeah yeah and
now we're here so you're right Queen
Johnny boy said Crouching Tiger Hidden
it's actually a beautiful play
I just can't remember the name of it I
don't know if I've ever heard of it you
know it if you saw it they have little
pom-poms on the head and I know people
say that so that's a that's denigrating
though so we'll look at this I don't
know how what to call them I don't know
what the history is it looks like a
Pom-Pom on the head looks like a Kevin
McAllister Christmas but top Christmas
in the Bronx stop it
all right here's another claim that they
make Rush Hour three Christmas
that's it so here's another claim that
they make in the film that the homie
valiantly fought Western Invaders trying
to take their freedom of course that's
untrue here's a clip fight
or we die
oh gosh I have to see another leaping
sword swipe
give me a wedding you must kill your
teeth
[Music]
we are the homie
[Music]
little Lawrence of a labia Vibe now
enough if it was just inaccurate right
where you were sort of whitewashing okay
we know that every everywhere slavery
existed everywhere it's actually worse
than that here's the truth
not only were they not fighting off
Western Invaders who are trying to
explain the agoji actually battled they
actually fought the French who were
actively trying to abolish slavery in
the tribe they were fighting to keep on
enslaving people yes and also by the way
so the French were saying we need to
abolish slavery okay so the film doesn't
really acknowledge that fully right also
unlike what you see in the film uh the
French wiped out the Goji in a matter of
hours oh so oh so they're the hold on so
it wasn't just a sneak attack bloodbath
with the giant John would jump like by
the way you can't jump and you don't
have leverage when you're in the air
with a sword like you know what happens
when you do that you've never seen that
style yeah somebody just holds a spear
up and says thank you exactly you're
skewered good job so wait a minute they
said that this is the most fearsome
fighting female force in the world
two hours
oh no we see you've set your Timex
[Laughter]
they're like we're going back all right
bye
and this is the issue here there is a
compulsion from the left
they view the world through the lens
again of Oppression and so if you are an
underdog you must be morally correct you
must be in the moral uh you must have
the moral High Ground I should say this
is why you see them support regardless
of where you line up with Israel
Palestine and none of us would deny that
Palestine even if you support that there
have been more morally reprehensible
actions taken but certainly Hamas right
if you certainly look at their chart on
the eradication of Jews if you look at
for example Iran if you look at right
now when they still support a lot of
Nations where there are still slave
traits just to be clear you look here
they say well hold on a second this uh
this this trap they must have been
morally correct why the truth is they
started from they were wiped out in
hours and worked backwards how can we
turn them into Heroes oh there were
women let's look at the different groups
of Oppression when the fact is they were
actually oppressing people by not only
enslaving them but fighting off the
people who wanted to liberate those
slaves to one degree or another and the
good news is they lost in record time
wow
everything about this film is wrong it's
almost like wakanda
is there like what kind of this actually
happened no that's what I mean wakanda
do you mean were the guys on top of a
Tesla with a spear pretty much it's the
story is just about as fake movies
they're like what we have all the most
brilliant technology in this magic and
then he's on top of like an electric car
with an invisibility cloak with a spear
like
what is this what is this these elements
don't add up
I don't care for the uh a lot of those
movies anyway yeah I know yeah you're
not a big big fan of the metaverse oh
one thing worse is DC here's another
claim that they make in this film uh
that America is the country and they
don't say it directly but again it's
sort of implied that the United States
is a country that built itself on
slavery or certainly more so than other
nations talk about being critical to a
nation's economy I guess you can imagine
some sort of Science Fiction world where
this didn't happen but this is what did
happen slave labor built the U.S and
their contributions weren't limited to
the South a little bit north in D.C
there's the White House we built that I
wake up every morning in a house that
was built by slaves okay and of course
we've seen actors who've worked on the
swiftly with the Press junkets where
they constantly want to berate the
United States and we'll get to the
Washington Post polls in a minute uh for
having Taken part of slavery again can
we can I say it any more clearly slavery
bad glad glad we ended slavery but
here's the truth the United States is
not only not singularly unique in having
engaged in slavery but Africa was
incredibly dependent the United States
wasn't entirely dependent on slavery the
United States would have become the
United States anyway because how do you
know because they were competing with
other nations it also had slavery just
to be clear so if you were to even that
playing field the United States would
still have a leg up left the world's
greatest superpower one century to
become the only superpower The Next
Century never happened before since just
to be clear
but countries in Africa relied on the
slave trade for economic growth the
Library of Congress uh their website
actually did show how African Traders
were major players and the page has
since been deleted hmm
interesting yeah you have the kingdom of
uh been in Benin I don't know again how
we pronounce it sometimes you only read
these words I'm American I'll say Ben
and Benihana Ben and her uh they sold
slaves to European Merchants for over
200 years places like Nigeria they
depended even more heavily on slavery
here's from the history News Network
many Nigerian middlemen began to depend
totally on their on the slave trade and
neglected every other business and
occupation the result and this is
important historical context because you
often look and again you'll have racists
who look when they say why is Africa
such a why are almost all countries in
Africa crap holes let's be clear racists
will look and say skin color that's not
what anyone here believe
you just look and say well maybe hold on
a second there has something to do with
modern Christendom
because they focused exclusively on
slavery at the cost of all other facets
of industry and historically that has
what has held these nations back the
result was uh the result was that when
the trade was abolished by England in
1807 these Nigerians began to protest as
years went by and the trade collapsed
such Nigerians lost their sources of
income and became impoverished and by
the way just to be clear we're going
back to the movie The homemaking they
were one of the most powerful slave
states on the whole what's known as the
slave coast of West Africa
how is it possible so I mean that makes
a great point right you made it against
the South as well saying look slavery
made you lazy slavery made you not
innovate like the North had to innovate
because they got rid of slavery and so
therefore they had to get better at
doing these things the entire western
coast of Africa essentially abandoned
all the natural resources that they say
that Africa is blessed with which it is
right it's got incredible natural
resources it's the credible civilization
exactly right so it has that and they
abandoned all of that for this how is
that the colonial oppression it's people
actually buying slaves from you that's
not being oppressed that's actually
engaging in Commerce now you're doing a
very bad form of Commerce I get it of
course and then the colonial oppressors
come and tell you to stop and focus on
something else that'll be a lot more
sustainable in the future and also not
you know also it's why I walk back zero
percent people got mad when I said look
slavery was not based on race
it was based on
slave it was based on precedent
precedence I guess in this case because
everyone else engaged in slavery we
thought well okay to compete slavery is
a thing
look at what happened in the the slave
Coast it was black people's living black
people you can look what's happened in
the Middle East it's Middle Eastern
people enslaving Middle Eastern you know
what's happened to Asia you have Asian
people enslaving Asian people it was
just a matter of which people were
available for purchase
to say that it's entirely racially
motivated or ethnically motivated like
the Holocaust where that was the express
purpose the eradication right we want to
basically commit a genocide against the
Jewish people that's not what happened
people didn't say hey we're only going
to enslave people of one particular race
because people of all different races
were enslaved depending on where they
existed in the world because slavery was
the norm here's something else all
references available a lot of
squatter.com I have said it several
times and it's one of those numbers
that's so shocking people say that can't
be right okay during the entire Atlantic
slave trade they're about 13 million
I've seen numbers as low as 12 million
I've seen numbers as high as 15 million
let's 13 million is the most accurate
that I can find
that's how many slaves were sold the
entire Atlantic slave trade right now on
Earth there are over 40 million slaves
today
jeez
and and the reason that people because
what often happens is they break it
apart those are sex slaves that's just
that's a worse form of slavery that's
slavery so if you look at some of these
websites where they sort of tally up
slavery they separate them into
different groups why I have a hunch as
to why
it's pretty hard to blame the United
States singularly for all the evils of
the world when today
the greatest evils that you blame
America for in their past they're still
being committed today
by nations with many people who live
there who you would claim are oppressed
here in the United States let's be let's
be really honest about that if you were
to take people from any of these
countries that still engage in slavery
bring them to the United States we would
say those are marginalized people
but in their home country they still
engage in slavery what here here we're
blamed for marginalizing them from
something that happened hundreds of
years ago I think that's why it's hard
to get but the number is 40 point
something million I think it's
40.240.3 million slaves on Earth today
you want to do something you want to
help the world don't go on Tick Tock and
[ __ ] about pronouns do something today
a lot of people say what would I have
done back then during that point in
history right if it was slavery here in
the United States what would I have I
like to say I'd like to think that I
would be someone who would have stood up
and done something I'd like to think
that I would have been one of the
Germans who would have stood up to the
SS and done something you can stand up
today
more slaves than other and there are
plenty of organizations that do a lot
out there especially with uh with with
sex slaves with those people being
trafficked yeah if you get a sex slave
don't pay for it right please don't ask
for a refund yeah by the way also only a
few years ago a few years ago libyans
were caught selling West Africans
open-air slave auctions just to be clear
that means out in the open oh Lord like
you at a flea market Only They were
selling people
this is very very recent that's the
issue what they try and say
conservatives are racist people on the
right are racist that's this reactionary
right review that you'll see from a
conservative in response to woman King
no no it's about accuracy
why aren't you talking about more slaves
than ever in recorded history who how
would I have been back then how are you
now
you're condemning the people now in this
studio for saying this is virtue
signaling [ __ ] there are slaves now
and you want to accuse us of being
racist for pointing it out while you
push
afro lesbian-centric propaganda I may
not be entirely right but I'm in the
ballpark
anything you guys can comment below did
you know that you know they're more
slaves than ever right now
until there's more slaves than ever in
recorded history all right uh we're
going to be moving on to uh Washington
Post uh I think this is something while
we're talking about you know racism
oh boy I'll tell you Corridor these
shows so awful it makes cardi B seem
bearable really
if I had a forklift
it has less to offer than Jimmy Kimmel
oh really what is that crying host have
to offer at least when I tune into that
I'm sure to see one whip see
okay guys that's that's I don't know why
we got the balcony I apologize mine
really there was a lot of money put into
this right hold on a second here on all
right so Gerald you're about to say
something no
thanks for throwing that to me
you were going to say something guys I'm
gay no I'm not gay I I really do want to
see you you brought this up earlier the
99 Rotten Tomatoes do you think there is
a way for them to massage that number I
understand the critics scores are always
I've never seen a 99 audience score for
anything well but it's also audience and
critics that's what I'm saying so high
it's like come on guys well if anything
about an audience it's that they always
love stuff yes
it's very easy to get an audience today
online to agree on something yeah
there's especially something as
polarizing as a woman King read anything
with comments yes
matter of fact sometimes if you need to
brighten your day go check the YouTube
yeah just just see how yeah I think you
guys are setting always leaves me with a
smile on my face no it doesn't while
we're talking about racism while we're
talking about the accusations of racism
Washington Post
um they are now at this point I would
say definitely diametrically opposed to
the interests of the American people
what do I mean by that okay so last week
and I wanted to make sure that uh some
research you know crossed my teeth dot
in my eyes gosh I have the hiccups today
and I don't think it's gonna come up
with the hiccups yeah I have horrible
hiccups your kids give them to you
someone can scare me in that way yeah
just give me an auditing uh paper so uh
The Washington Post uh there's a
columnist there Jennifer Rubin who wrote
a piece now this is an opinion piece
granted but the opinion piece is based
on
a pull from an institution and I'll get
to that this is what happens I said well
this is opinion but it's based on fact
right I'm I'm planning on something that
we know as effect so it seems as though
you've started with a baseline where
Americans Maga Republicans are racist
it's a really brilliant sort of sleight
of hand trick right you're going hold on
a second when you see this where's the
pull from you're prominent so this is
the name of the article it's just how
racist is the Maga movement this survey
measures it and uh to answer your it is
exactly as stupid as you would assume it
is do me a favor too and researchers
pull up some of Jennifer rubin's uh best
Tweets this if you don't know who this
person is
she is a no fan of anybody who is
conservative period whether you're a
Donald Trump conservative or anybody
else right and this is an opinion
article to be clear but
I'm an opinion journalist I understand
but the poll is not the poll just so you
know Reuben's article uses survey data
from the public religion Research
Institute so PRI to prove that
Republicans are racist so it starts off
with the foundation that obviously
Republicans are racist and then
obviously Maga Republicans are racist
yeah so they get you to buy that then
it's a lot easier to get you to buy
another lie just like if they get you to
buy the lie that the homies we're
fighting right we're fighting to try and
uh first off that they're even remotely
successful in fighting off the French
Beyond two hours Beyond a long lunch
break uh to try and freeze No in fact
they were fighting to maintain slavery
so if you believe when I start off from
the jumping off point here Republicans
are racist then you get to say I'm
writing an opinionist asking why are all
Republicans racist so just to be clear
the PRI they describe themselves as
quote a non-profit nonpartisan
organization dedicated to conducting an
independent research at the intersection
of religion culture and public policy
now you should note they partner with
the Atlantic they partner with the Roper
Center at Cornell and the Brookings
Institute so that should give you an
idea as to where they line up the survey
asks for responses to 11 statements
designed to measure racism okay and
basically you do you agree do you
disagree Right This Is How They This Is
How They conduct these polls and the
answers were used to create a structural
racism score
comment below right now before you
actually watch and see where we're going
if you can tell where this is going
don't take the test so here are some
examples of statements that are included
to which people would again agree or
disagree and that tells you if you're
racist or not
it's a structural racism course
basically if you answer this question
with agree or disagree depending on the
statement you are in fact uh of course
uh a racist so here's a statement do you
believe white Americans today are not
responsible for discrimination against
black people in the past logical fallacy
alert just to be clear that's called a
negative question
now a negative question is a type of
question where a no response indicates
an affirmative answer and a yes
indicates a negative answer and common
practice with polling you're not
supposed to use this unless you're
intentionally being dishonest so let's
go back to this question do you believe
white Americans today
today white Americans today are not
responsible for discrimination against
black people in the past the answer if
you're going to be accurate is of course
agree
yes am I the question is not are white
were white Americans responsible for
discrimination against black people in
the past the answer everyone here would
say well yeah of course of course they
were
but then if they say Do you believe that
white Americans today are not
responsible for discrimination against
black but of course Gerald's not
responsible for what happened back
during the slave trade I've seen his
time machine
DeLorean yeah exactly no one here of
course we would say well yeah of course
of course uh I agree we're not
responsible for discrimination against
black people in the past you
Mind by the way answering for other
people who've come before you and then
you've asked the question with a
negative so there's two tricks there
designed to trip people up and by the
way this is then used as though it is
concrete data indicating that half of
this country is racist and you can bet
your ass that you're going to have uh or
you're going to have the White House use
this as the backbone for some of their
arguments the alarming level of
extremism you don't think the FBI is
glad to have this
you better say something in there I was
gonna I just I can't believe you start
off or not even start off but wherever
that question happens to reside in there
that you ask a question like that and
it's not just that question it's the
narrative that we see from the left
continuously is that people white people
today are responsible for the decisions
made
150 to 200 years ago by other white
people it's like that doesn't make any
sense at all because if we could play
that game we could just rewind the tape
a little bit further like you were
saying and say okay well the black
people that went and caught the slaves
are then responsible as well you don't
even need to rewind it further you can
just ask them in the present tense
that's true do you agree that uh slavery
that goes on today in Africa and the
Middle East and Asia is wrong
does that make you racist
because these tend to be people of a
particular race in these countries and
it's not because of their race that they
are employing slavery it's because of
their history it's because of their
values which we don't share in the
modern world and you try and look at the
modern world through the lens of the
values that were created through the
judeo-christian founding fathers and the
documents therein
and then condemn them
ah it's a theoretical Wormhole slave
trade question yes
with the word not in it which is always
great in a question because that's meant
to confuse you exactly it's the Event
Horizon of polls yes I need a flowchart
to see where I'm responsible but they
thrown the word not that's what I hate
about questions like that is because
it's deliberately meant to confuse you
so you answer wrong number these are not
people who are looking for an accurate
assessment these are people who are
looking to manipulate 100 right yeah
look it's very simple this is how you
would ask that question uh do you think
that uh Americans engage in
discrimination or pegatory in the past
yes
are you a bigot or are you prejudiced
are you racist no there you go that's a
more accurate question as opposed to
combining them into one and implying
that well on a second if you don't think
that you're responsible for past racism
that makes you racist today this is not
someone who is seeking to get to the
truth and that's why I always say be
very very leery of polls right you can't
just argue from the position of most
people think this first off that may not
be the case second you have to look at
the kinds of questions that were asked
here are other questions posed in the
first one do you feel that the white
people of Tomorrow are responsible for
the racism of today
I'd be willing to bet yes okay probably
I just want to make sure because of all
the white guilt yes I do not want to see
what white people do tomorrow oh it's
rough it's it's one of those it's like
Back To The Future Three of slavery they
live in the sewers like Demolition Man
yes
oh I'm thinking of time cop that's right
yeah they're both good yes they're both
fantastic
here's another question pose in the
survey white supremacy a statement I
should say white supremacy is still a
major problem in the United States today
agree or disagree
first off wrong you've also added a call
major oh that's subjective what do you
mean major problem do you mean and this
is if we would have a conversation white
supremacy and this is why we do change
my mind where you can discuss these
issues at length ironically for you know
the left they always say that they live
in the Nuance well look at this pole
here the nuancers a major problem do you
mean for example major in that are there
any actual legal institutions that exist
today that are allowed to discriminate
you know aside from examples like
affirmative action or racial or
diversity no it doesn't exist so I
wouldn't say it's a major problem in the
United States today because it doesn't
exist anywhere
systemically now if you say white
supremacy is still a major problem in
the U.S today and you disagree guess
what that goes on your structural racism
score
makes you a racist let me give you
another question good luck in a not
racist house yes
7.8 percent oh it's geez thanks Joe
Biden agree or disagree if we truly want
to repent of the history of racism in
the United States we must be willing to
repair the damage it has done to
generations of black Americans let me
read that again because I know it's hard
to say agree or disagree when it's
filled to the brim with [ __ ] if we
truly want to repent of the history of
racism in the United States we must be
willing to repair the damage it has done
to generations of black Americans now
there there's a Litany of reasons that
you could disagree with that statement
first off repair the damage well
alongside what do you mean what damage
and then how do you repair the damage
and what do you mean repent and the
history of racism how are we qualifying
the history of racism which kind of
racism are we just talking about slavery
which by the way still exists in the
world are we also talking about what
happened during World War II in the
internment camps are we talking about
what happened with Jewish Americans by
the way we didn't treat them all that
well right from leading up until World
War II that's another thing that
Americans don't necessarily talk about
we've made mistakes but which kind of
racism and what kind of damage what to
what level to what degree of damage
needs to be repaired and how do we
repair it so I would just have to
encapsulate that with disagree
racist and then you get it in the media
then you get on Washington Post then it
goes to the White House then it's used
by the FBI CIA doj to put you on a list
so you should just say you're you're
racist yes
but yeah no you made the black it's not
always just about black people what what
about black people being racist to white
people right what about what about white
people being racist when it comes to
Chinese Americans building the railroads
out in Cal you know California and on
the west right there are so many
examples that you just gave what about
black people being racist towards
Chinese people or black people being
racist towards other black people right
for example so all about Chinese being
racist to Japanese and you're watching
it and you're like I don't know what so
what's up right well when we it's like
Clone Wars when we tried to fix the
problem of slavery the problem that
slavery created of course there are
better ways that we can look at problems
sometimes we don't always do the very
best job of solving it but one of the
easiest things that we said was okay
look we just need to give everybody the
same opportunity the same Opportunity by
the way that we had when we came here
from England right that opportunity no
guarantee of success if you work hard
you can make it that took a little while
we are over a century beyond that and
we're still talking about trying to fix
the problem and the only way that people
can say that we can fix that problem is
by being racist today in creating a
future problem right so black people
need to be preferenced over white people
Kamala Harris just the other day I
believe said something about funding
going for Hurricane Ian to communities
of color first well I will say the only
way I will say though that I do respect
her because you know if she were being
selfish looking out for her own best
interests of course she she won't see a
dime
if they were the ones hit first but
that's the solution it's like okay so we
just put it on the water right and then
eventually we we have such a problem
with white people like 100 years from
now white people women slavery and
racism and everything else led to me
being oppressed and now I need to
oppress somebody else so that I can make
the playing field level do you see this
game ever ending no and that's the goal
and this is why I say they are
diabetically opposed to the interest of
All American people black white Johnny
Mathis black white yellow no one knows
we know Jesus wasn't yellow
if you want at the end of the segment we
can play the agree disagree game with
Jennifer rubin's tweets oh
this is a structural racism score that
they then use to say that you as a Maga
Republican are a racist
uh and by the way the poll never
actually uses the term Monger they just
Define it afterwards like oh this must
be a market person so Republican really
equals Maga so they have Republicans
0.67 again on these structural racism
score independent 0.45 Democrat 0.27 and
by the way they have structural racism
scores by religious groups white
Evangelical Protestants 0.64 white
Latter-Day Saints 0.55 white Catholic
0.55 white Mainline Protestant 0.55 and
here's the thing they say Reuben
describes these people as the religious
groups that make up the core of today's
GOP and Maga movement ah so white
Protestants white evangelicals I noticed
that they don't include black
Protestants which by the way is most
black people just degrading on a curve
yeah uh these evil racist groups this is
something else I don't want to bring up
very generous by the way across the
board so being important philanthropy or
Round Table there's also a great book I
talked about by Brooks who really cares
Evangelical Protestants and Mormons in
particular are strong givers compared to
Protestant affiliation both Catholic
affiliation and Jewish affiliation
reduce the scope of average giving when
other influences are held constant
Finance grain numbers from the PSID show
that the faithful don't just give to
religious causes that's another lie that
people they just give to the church
right by the way the church does more
charitable giving and by the way acts of
service than the government could ever
hope to do just to be good there is no
no larger charitable institution that
exists not just for Christians than the
American Evangelical Church just to be
clear hey when we're talking about this
where's the uh where's the where's the
International Islamic charity
organizations for people who aren't
Islamic no that's precluded from their
faith might be why in a lot of Islamic
Nations they still engage in slavery see
there's a tie back so not just religious
causes they are also more likely to give
to secular causes than the non-religious
and to conclude the article Reuben using
this poll by the way
these polls from this organization
claims that 85 percent of Republicans
want to rewrite history of the Civil War
and ignore the evil of slave what yes in
other words if you say I'm not
responsible for racism of the past I'm
responsible for my actions she then
concludes that you want to rewrite
history
this is the goal the goal is to fracture
you the goal is to make the goal is to
make racism worse today than ever than
ever to create more racial tensions than
ever so that you can be scapegoated you
can be blamed you can be you can be
categorized as an extremist simply for
saying no I don't think I'm responsible
for something that happened hundreds of
years ago here's an actual here's actual
text for your ancestors probably won't
even hear let's be honest right for most
white people I mean realistic mine
weren't that's yeah again we go through
generations of immigrants yeah this is
it's just it doesn't where's the Nuance
left here's actual text by the way from
the survey Americans are divided over
whether they support or oppose efforts
to preserve the Legacy and history not
the same thing Legacy in history not the
same thing you pair those together
you've just you've just rendered the
poll completely unusable efforts to
preserve the Legacy and history of the
Confederacy through public memorials and
statues in their Community 51 supported
46 percent opposed 85 percent support
from Republicans Democrats 26 percent
support which is kind of of funny
because A Confederacy was made up of
almost entirely Democrats to be clear I
don't know if you know this little I
don't know if your history Buffs out
there hmm
but while we're talking about the Civil
War and the Confederacy now preserving
the history means that Republicans are
saying even though we don't have a dog
in that fight because we weren't the
Confederates that was you guys saying
yeah I don't think you should take down
every single statue yeah I don't think
you should completely remove history it
is a part of our history if you don't
recognize history you're doomed to
repeat it that says no you want to
preserve the Legacy because you support
the Confederacy well one second I
believe that we should have World War I
believe we should have Holocaust museums
monuments I believe that we should
recognize it I believe that it should be
mandatory teaching in schools so that we
learn how evil human beings can truly be
it doesn't mean that I want to preserve
the legacy of Hitler right and the
survey by the way again never mentions
rewriting the Civil War yeah that's
important they go afterwards and say
well that must be you want to rewrite
the Civil War what
yeah well they're talking about the
Confederacy like you you didn't mention
the fighting that took place to actually
free slaves the white people who fought
other white people to make sure that
they couldn't have slaves just like the
white people fought black people in
Africa to make sure they stopped selling
slaves who were enslaved by other black
people other black people yes it seems
like we've I think we've done that's
actually a really good point like you
know we've talked about people said I
can't believe that you would say slavery
isn't predicated on Race okay again just
using the woman King as an example when
you talk about the French going in in
the Dahomey tribe you have black people
enslaving black people now you have
different people enslaving people
members of different races all
throughout history but let's just use
this as a very clear example black
people enslaving black people selling
them okay so they are selling them to
either other black people or selling
them to other white people and you have
people like the French go in and try and
abolish slavery so white people trying
to abolish the practice of black people
enslaving black people yeah same thing
with the United States white people
fighting white people to say you can no
longer enslave black and we ignore black
people enslaved black people white
people fought white people to stop
enslaving black people who just say it's
a black white thing no it's a human
nature thing
that's all it doesn't make it any less
morally reprehensible but to say that
it's racially motive and this is what's
so subversive about this too it's not
just you can't say something because it
offends me right that's where people
talk about cancer culture it's worse
than that it's uh hold on a second you
actually can't say that because you're
simply reinforcing the power structures
that be the racism structural index
score whatever the hell they call it
you're actually doing harm to current
black people by reinforcing racial
structures that exist so it's not you're
saying something I don't like but the
very fact that you have the ability to
say it is a byproduct of free speech
from racist white founding fathers so
it's like two evils that you're
committing think about that for a second
that's how can anyone have a
conversation
and if that same logic were applied you
would have never had the Civil Rights
Act
because it's all great civil rights
movements start through what speech no
matter how offensive it may be now
apparently the prri director Robert P
Jones doesn't have any problem with
Reuben's characterization this is what
uh was said while this result may seem
surprising or even shocking to many
white Christians no no inaccurate it is
because we do not know our own history
yes we do if we take a clear-eyed look
at our history we see a widespread
centuries-long Christian defense of
white supremacy let me ask you something
you're looking at percentage because a
lot of people were Christians sure that
doesn't mean that it was a Christian
defense of white supremacy just not
clear a lot of them were trying to
defend uh slavery in spite
of what would be Christian beliefs how
many uh
Hindus
how many Hindus abolish slavery because
of the tenets of Hinduism
how many Muslims
abolished labor because of again the
fundamental values of Islam there's
still slavery that exists
by the way exists in parts of India and
they're still slavery that exists in the
Middle East so can you find any other
group of people who opposed slavery more
than white Christians here in the United
States
the largest percentage of the population
you're going to have Christians who were
on the side of slavery but the arguments
used to abolish slavery were entirely
biblically based on the moral component
not the economic component the arguments
used to preserve slavery from the
so-called white Christians had to go
outside the scope of the Bible and they
had to be entirely economically argued
yeah by the way we have a a Christian in
the white house supposedly right now
who's pro-abortion which goes completely
against what the Bible says so it's just
an example that Christians don't always
stand up and say and by the way do you
think William Wilberforce was an
agnostic right I've never heard of him
but no yeah no fantastic guy you should
read up on him I'll give a gander he
wanted more slaves that's what it was
yes it was more slaves than women yes
how many slaves did Jesus have uh you
know I don't know one can never count in
the 50s right he just had 12 losers who
were sort of you know riding his
coattails I know right
man sorry I'm just saying come on let's
be we all know who was putting bread on
the table there I mean you give him Five
Loaves yes the Bible says white people
are Supreme when it was talking about
all Middle Eastern people and the chosen
people being Jewish
saying that yes and by the way we don't
mean Jewish like you think of them here
in the United States we mean Jewish who
would look more like what you would yes
picture a terrorist to look like yes yes
like Middle Eastern Mediterranean yeah
yeah very Mediterranean yeah Bible
That's that white supremacist where did
I give you my only son this short brown
man who's not very attractive have you
read any of the book
and by the way I'm not saying he's not
attractive because he's Middle Eastern
I'm saying he's not attractive because
the Bible describes him as nothing
special to see yes physically so don't
make it a racial argument Washington
Post or prri
Ed it'll be the first time they defended
Jesus yes
the church yeah that'd be a win if we
could get them to accidentally defend
Jesus right all right so we're actually
so look and I want to hear I want to
hear from you would you agree to go take
go look at the survey tell me how you
would have answered this poll
because I want you to not feel bad for
answering accurately that's the thing I
think too many people are timid with
this at this point and sometimes I want
I want to be tactful because I don't
want to turn off people who I could
otherwise reach no no let your freak
flag fly be honest about it you cannot
argue from a position of weakness oh
well I don't think that I'm responsible
for pests slavery or racism but uh let
me let me listen no no no I don't need
to listen to your argument that I am
responsible
for acts of evil committed 100 years ago
I don't need to listen to that it is not
accurate it's it also it also won't
allow us to have a productive
conversation if it has any bearing on
this conversation because we have we'll
be we'll be in two different parallel
Lanes we'll never actually intersect you
love that word afro-lesbian Centrix by
the way we're going to play the Jennifer
the Reuben game I guess we'll play that
on Mud Club we have a lot more to get to
so if you are watching right now on
YouTube the best thing you can do by the
way hit like leave a comment share the
show
and you can share the show that's a good
thing if you can do you want to hit
sharing is caring
it's different I didn't really be
changing we don't have the rainbow
anymore we have another hour of show to
do on mud club.com be taking your chat
YouTube thank you but not really piss
off
[Music]
foreign